sorry falls mein linkes auge so ein
bisschen rot ist aber ich habe mein
garten blumenkohl rein gesamte hier
allerdings erst mal herzlich willkommen
hier meine damen und herren a ha das hat
wehgetan herzlich willkommen hier heute
zu einem neuen video auf einem kanal und
meine damen und herren wir reden heute
mal wieder mit dem clever bot den habe
ich gerade schon gefragt was geht und
darauf antwortete er alles was beine hat
außer tische und stühle davon wirklich
der witz des jahrtausends ich wollte
dann zu ihm du bist wohl ganz lustig
dann schreibt er danke ich kein ding und
erstellen wir noch eine frage also wie
heißt du frage ich ihn jetzt einfach mal
er wollte ja eine frage haben ich heiße
brender okay der clever bot ist also
weiblich möchtest du auch wissen wie ich
heiße frage ich ihn dann mal als hätte
mich ja noch nicht nach meinem namen
gefragt jan luca heiße ich mal lieber
clever bot oder meine leber clever
bottini ich dachte du bist ein mädchen
na ja nur weil du brender heißt und
mädchen bis muss ich ja nicht auch
gleich ein mädchen sein nein bin eine
junge schreibe ich deswegen einfach mal
zurück ach so und sie heiß wird drei
nachrichten davor ich gesagt dass sich
luca heiße habe ich doch gerade schon
gesagt lieber clever bottini brender
keine ahnung was hast du nicht dicker da
oben steht dass sich luca heiße
natürlich habe ich das gesagt drei
ausrufezeichen meine liebe brender
klasse antwort warum lachst so komisch
liebe brender weil ich sich gerade
beobachtet
ok bist du ein mädchen du hast mich grad
schon gefragt ob ich ein mädchen bin was
mache ich hier mit meinem leben ich bin
noch immer ein junger und heiße lukas
schöner name ich liebe dich
auch brender wie so liebst du mich also
ich meine sie weiß ja überhaupt nichts
über mich du bist der beste mensch der
welt danke das sagen so einige zum ihrem
hals mal danke aber wieso liebe brender
ich mag dein charakter astro okay weil
du ja auch schon so viel über mich weiß
ich sag jetzt einfach ich liebe dich
auch willst du mich hat das bestimmt
thema bord und mir das sechzehnte kleine
liebesbeziehung weiß ich noch nicht
punkt für punkt schreibe ich meine
heirat muss man sich ich liebe jemand
anderes alles klar das ging relativ
schnell in wien bist du jetzt verliebt
brender frage ich sie einfach mal in ein
mädchen okay krass wie heißt sie denn
also wie heißt das mädchen in das du
verliebt bist ich bin in keiner
beziehung das müssen wir noch mal lernen
die beziehung geschrieben wird in der
tat soll ich will spielen also soll ich
sie so ein bisschen verkuppeln mit dem
mädchen was
ob ich euch verkuppeln soll punkt punkt
punkt fragezeichen
nee lass mal okay dann lasse ich das
reden weil es allerdings mal über ein
anderes thema mit dem clever bot und
zwar eines meiner ersten videos die ich
auf dieser website aufgenommen habe ein
video wo der clever und exakt erraten
hat was ich für klamotten an habe es hat
die farbe schwarz
jetzt wegen frage
aber einfach mal welche farbe hat mein t
shirt die man schauen ob die brände mir
das vorher soll ich das wissen alles
klar früher konnte er mehr genau sagen
blaue unterhose weiße socken welche
haarfarbe habe ich es ist nicht wahr ich
würde raus will
keine ahnung punkt punkt punkt schreibe
ich einfach mal so ich weiß nicht woher
das ist soll siehst du das macht keinen
sinn okay dass das stimmt das stimmt da
gebe ich ihm recht aber ich bin doch
nicht müll
tue ich hier
ich rede mit einer website
wieso rede ich überhaupt mit dir punkt
punkt punkt fragezeichen ich hab dich
auch ganz dolle lieb wollen wir heiraten
ich bin noch zu jung wie alt bist du
lieber liebe bertha brender die brander
hieß
hat sie noch gar nicht gesagt das hast
du mir noch nicht gesagt kommt natürlich
vor hin
nein
du hast mir in diesem video noch nicht
gesagt wie alt du bist ich bin 22 jahre
alt und du liebe brender du bist 22 ja
das habe ich ja gerade geschrieben
sehr schön wie siehst du aus mega sexy
mega sexy sehe ich aus liebe brender und
du bist ein junger japaner brender ich
bin eine junge mal schauen ob cool ich
bin ein mädchen super wir drehen uns
überhaupt nicht im kreis mit unserer
unterhaltung super und was machst du
gerade so frage ich dann einfach mal mit
dir reden das war tatsächlich eine sehr
schlagfertige antwort und was machst du
nachher noch so frage ich dann mal
vielleicht könnte ich auf dem date geht
mit der brender nicht zu
auch nichts und dann schicke ich mal das
erste mal einen smiley an die liebe gott
das ein punkt wollen wir uns nachher
treffen umbringt
es ist so als würde der mein mikro das
ding mein mikro ab das habe ich mir
schon oft gefragt weil diese website
weiß wirklich sehr häufig an was ich
denke und in welche richtung ist die
unterhaltung steuern will aber gut ich
würde einfach mal sagen ja lasst uns
nachher treffen ok und was machen wir
dann wir könnten konkreter videos
schauen sich jetzt einfach mal so
richtig nervig auch die herr antwort
macht überhaupt keinen sinn wollen wir
nachher neue videos von luca schauen
wenn du ein junge bist dann ja ich bin
ein junger also anscheinend haben wir
dann also ein date dann können wir
zusammen sein
können wir zusammen sein
das heißt wir sind jetzt in der
beziehung sind wir nun in einer
liebesbeziehung frage ich jetzt einfach
mal ich weiß nich hen du hast gerade
doch geschrieben wir können zusammen
sein warum wahrscheinlich aber auf
meinen tisch das tut einfach nur weh
willst du mit mir zusammen sein oder
nicht lieber brender jetzt nach einfach
keine ahnung ich habe ja schon einen
freund auf einmal hast du schon freund
ich dachte du bist in keiner beziehung
das hat sie ja zu beginn geschrieben ein
punkt punkt punkt ich bin zwölf aber du
willst sicher nicht mit mir zusammen
sein
du bist 12
ich bin 22 das sind zehn jahren
natürlich kann mir zusammen sein sind
doch nur zehn jahre unterschied hh ok
also bis zu 16 jahre alt genau 12 + 10
ist 16 genau genau ab um punktgenau xd
schreibe ich einfach mal bock auf
diese website will einfach mit mir
japans bock auf was frage ich einfach
mal auf eine beziehung mit einem anderen
mädchen
weiß der clever bot dass ich mit jule
zusammenbinden und will mich gerade zum
fremdgehen überreden ein punkt um punkt
ich bin bereits in einer beziehung mit
der lieben jule schauen was dabei aber
da seid doch du bist schon teil
okay doch bist du schon teil erster sich
heißt du nicht schon teil
zweitens weißt du gar nichts über mich
wieso chantal also ich weiß nicht wie
brender jetzt auf chantal kommt weil du
das sagt ist
ich habe nie chantal gesagt wann soll
ich das bitte gesagt haben punkt um
punkt fragezeichen also ich weiß nicht
woher die worte nimmt gar nicht weil du
das sagt ist und dann waren soll ich das
gesagt haben gar nicht lieber clever bot
ecke brender
was bist du für eine bescheuerte website
das ist keine schöne frage das gleiche
schreibe ich jetzt noch mal hier rein
was bist du für eine bescheuerte
webseite und brenda antwortet nein ich
bin nur ein junger punkt
alter erst ist sie mädchen dann ist
jetzt wieder ein junge was bist du denn
jetzt überhaupt clever bot ich weiß
nicht was du bist ich bin ein mädchen
und zwölf jahre alt und hier sagt sie
nein ich bin nur ein junge 12 jahre
altes mädchen oder junge punkt ich weiß
nicht was ich glauben soll ich habe dir
schon drei mal gesagt dass ich ein junge
leute warum bin ich auf dieser website
und schreibe mit diesem ding
an der stelle wird das heutige video ist
allerdings ob band meine damen und
herren mir kommen bei diesem clever
bordvideos echt immer die nerven auf
meinen kopf level dann da dann wie ich
weiß nicht warum ich das mache deswegen
ich und ich bin einfach echt am arsch
das war echt überhaupt keinen deut schen
euch dieses video allerdings gefallen
hat liebe lufteinlass gerne einen daumen
hoch bei diesem video da soll ich
eventuell mal wieder öfter videos mit
dem clever bord hochladen streits wir
gerne unten in die kommentare und jetzt
gehe ich kotzen und ihr könnt ihr euch
das auto hier anschauen und meinen kanal
abonnieren
[Musik]